[Music]  Christina Applegate who amid her battle  with Ms made a triumphant return to the  spotlight with a star on the Hollywood  Walk of Fame and a Little Help from her  TV mama  [Applause]  the 50 year old stood Barefoot with the  support of a walking stick while  delivering Her speech longtime friend  Selma Blair who also battles Ms was  there for support along with dead to  me's Linda Cardellini and Married With  Children's David Faustino fond memories  are our laughter together her dry humor  her dry humor is on another level I love  the fact that to this day you still call  me Mommy  I love you so much my sweetheart you're  not alone we're all here we love you the  most important  person in this world is my daughter  everything  thank you for standing beside me through  all of this oh by the way I have a  disease um anyway  um did you not notice  I'm not even wearing shoes  [Music]